Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today.
Tim Maudlin, who's the founder and director
of the John Bell Institute for the Foundations
of Physics and also professor of philosophy
at New York University.
Really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 8: Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So let's let's get into metaphysics
a little bit and give some some in our audience
some tools with which to understand this concept.
Very often, people on the Internet love making
videos about metaphysics, and they seem to
have no idea what we're even talking about.
So so, you know, one analogy that I've used
and you tell me whether this gets us in the
right direction, if we want to understand
how the moon got to exist and where it is,
gravity would be part of of understanding
that metaphysics would look at how did gravity
get created?
Was there a before gravity?
Is that is that an example of what we talk
about when we say physics versus metaphysics?
Speaker 8: Well, unfortunately, just the language
physics and metaphysics makes it sound like
what you just said.
And a lot of people use it that way.
Historically, that's not what it is at all.
Okay.
Metaphysics, there was a document that came
down to us from Aristotle that a later editor
called The Metaphysics.
Aristotle never used the term.
And what he's doing in that is looking at
what we call ontology or just the genesis
general theory of what exists carried out
at the most general high level scale.
Right.
So not gee, is there a you know, is there
a rock over here?
But are there rocks at all?
And what are rocks made of?
So from that point of view, it's not that
you go beyond physics to do metaphysics.
I actually have a book called The Metaphysics
Within Physics, because physics makes postulates
about, at a fundamental level, what exists.
That's part of metaphysics.
Now, maybe not everything is physical, so
metaphysics would go further than that if
there are nonphysical things.
But part of it is just the basic picture of
what exists physically.
Now, gravity exists physically.
Okay.
Yeah, gravity is part of it.
Is there a story about where gravity came
from?
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Maybe that's just kind of ground level stuff
once you get down to the law of gravity.
There's no further account of that.
That's the bottom level of everything.
Speaker 1: When we think about things like
the relationship between mind and body, which
can have religious aspects to the discussion,
scientific, philosophical, consciousness,
free will, these sorts of things.
Are these all conversations that include both
what we might consider traditional hard science
as well as metaphysics?
Or are they only that depending on the preconceived
notions one brings to the conversation?
Speaker 8: No, I mean the sorts of questions
you're asking.
Certainly the mind body problem involves fundamental
metaphysical questions if you think there
is a nonphysical soul.
Some people do.
Some people don't.
If you do, then there's an issue of how it
can interact with a physical body, right?
And that the interaction would have to go
both ways.
If you think there is and then you have to
say, well, how is it that just physical stuff
doing something could give rise to consciousness
and awareness.
That's a very deep problem as well.
So there's no easy answers here.
There are different answers, and each answer
kind of involves its own questions that that
that run on from it.
So, yeah, I mean, metaphysics certainly gets
involved in those kinds of questions.
Speaker 1: When I've talked to scientists
about the question what was there before the
universe, the answers obviously are always
couched in we don't actually know.
But one question is, was there really a before
the universe, which is a hard thing to think
about because it seems, if you understand
time linearly, that there must have been some
before or some beginning or something like
that.
What what does metaphysics have to add to
that question?
Speaker 8: Well, it's not that metaphysics
is going to ride to the rescue and provide
answers to this.
I mean, the questions you ask again are good
questions.
Is there anything before, let's say, this
universe now, one possible answer to that
is, yeah, there was another universe and before
that, maybe another one and before that maybe
another.
And then there's a question of how one arises
out of another.
Maybe you say as you say.
One possible answer is, Look, there was no
before this universe, and that might be because
time goes on forever.
Or it might be the time doesn't even go on
forever.
But nonetheless, there's only so much of it.
You sort of there's only a limited amount.
This is the kind of standard big Bang theory.
You go back 13.7 billion years and there is
nothing before that.
So it's not that that came out.
Of anything earlier.
There was no earlier.
These are different answers.
Right.
And cosmologists have proposed different theories
that answer these questions in different ways.
It's not as if metaphysician have some magic
wand that they're going to give you the right
answer.
If you're well-trained in philosophy, you
can at least delineate, look, there's this
answer.
There's this answer, There's this answer.
Let's see how they differ.
Let's see what observations might bear on
this and questions like that.
Speaker 1: I think one of the areas where
laypeople sometimes come up against I don't
know if frustration or despair or existential
crises is the right term, but with some of
these questions, what becomes tough is that
it can seem as though you either have to say,
I'm going to try to answer some of these questions
simply with science, because that's the only
place where the scientific method exists,
and that's all I'm comfortable with in terms
of confidence in what we either know or don't
know.
Or I have to look at a different path altogether,
which would be philosophy, metaphysics, etc..
And that can be frustrating because some people
feel like I'm kind of pre selecting where
the end point for me is going to be in some
of these questions by choosing one of these
two paths, almost like a fork in the road.
Is that an understandable frustration?
But more importantly, is it an accurate critique
or observation?
Maybe is the right word?
Speaker 8: So I think you have something particular
in mind there.
And let me just point it out, because you
say, oh, there's the scientific way and then
there are other ways.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm saying if someone feels
that way, are they right or is that not the
right interpretation or understanding?
Speaker 8: The first thing I would say is
sort of any discipline where you provide what
we think is good reasons to believe what you're
proposing counts is a kind of science sometimes
that's experimental or observational.
But notice when we divide the university into
the arts and sciences, the math departments
in the sciences, right?
Yeah, it works on observations, but because
it works by arguments, by proofs.
Right?
You say, Look, I have a reason that I can
give to you for for accepting this answer.
From that point of view, anything that really
has good evidence, any anybody that's putting
forward good evidence for what they're claiming
is doing science, whatever else you call it.
And if something doesn't count as science,
then you're just saying, well, I'm putting
forward opinions and I have no good reasons
for them.
And I would say, well, that's not such a great
thing to do.
Now, there are limits to science.
There may be things that you'd like to know
that we're just not in a position to know.
And if there are, there are.
I mean, you just have to live, you know, live
with the limitations of the world.
Speaker 1: What are, in your mind, some of
the most interesting questions or problems
that are being looked at in in terms of metaphysics
and philosophy right now that maybe may be
familiar to our audience or may not be?
Speaker 8: Well, since I specialize in foundations
of physics, the one you mentioned, like, how
is there a beginning to the entire universe
cosmos?
And if so, what was it like?
And could there be anything that we would
count as an explanation for why it was like
that?
I think that's a very interesting question.
There are much more detailed questions about
how to understand quantum theory, what you
know, what picture of the world that you can
really comprehend could result in the kind
of phenomena we see in the lab that we associate
with quantum theory.
They're very interesting.
I mean, I could go into detailed questions
there, but I'm sure that would take us beyond
the scope of this this interview.
But I work in foundations of physics, so of
course, I tend to those there are people who
are worried about how did life begin?
Right.
That's how how could living things have would
have have come out of non-living things.
And that's a very interesting question.
I mean, and I've heard interesting answers
having to do with how clay forms and, you
know, various kind of inorganic structures
that could help create the sorts of complexity
that we need for life and so on.
That would be in biology.
An interesting question.
So there are lots of them in different places.
I happen to live in the in the physics part
of it.
Speaker 1: I recently read a couple of books
about solipsism, and one of the claims that
all of these books made was that unlike with
many other philosophies of reality in time,
there's been no refutation, satisfactory refutation
of the idea that all we can really be certain
of is our own existence.
Right now, as we are thinking about it, that
even our memories that we believe we have
experienced, we may not actually have experience.
Someday they may have been implanted in our
brains, as you and I are speaking today.
In other words, I don't know that I really
had an apple an hour ago.
I have the memory of having had that apple
and that there's been no satisfactory refutation
of.
That doesn't mean that it is that it is true.
To opt to choose this one when it comes to
thinking about time and the passage of time,
etc..
What if someone who do the does the work you
do think about such an assertion?
Speaker 7: Well.
Speaker 8: Let me just check because there's
a little linguistic question I have.
You said you read books about solipsism.
Did you mean that or skepticism?
Because it sounded like you were right.
Speaker 1: I meant solipsism.
Speaker 8: You meant solipsism.
Well, solipsism is a view.
It's a very definite view.
It sort of says the only thing that exists
is me.
I mean, that.
That.
Okay, that's a possible view.
It's kind of crazy.
I mean, there's so.
Speaker 1: Even someone like you is comfortable
refuting it by saying it's kind of crazy.
Speaker 8: Well, you would say if you want
by a refutation and absolute proof, you're
not going to get it.
Okay.
It's not that the solipsism has an absolute
proof of any sort that solipsism is true.
So you can't you can't give that standard
to your enemies.
You say you enemies.
You have to prove your case beyond any doubt.
And me, I can just say whatever I want.
Speaker 1: So it's a question of burden, of
proof in a sense.
Speaker 8: So, you know, solipsism, I mean,
the view that only I exist, I think has literally
nothing to say for.
Of course, there are things other than me.
There are tables and chairs.
And if I leave the room, as HUME would say,
if I leave the room and the fire is burning
and I come back later, it's a bunch of ashes.
Why?
Because it kept burning all the time when
I wasn't there.
I mean, that's the obvious explanation.
It's not you know, you can say, I could make
up, maybe I'm in the Matrix, maybe there's
some ETS.
You can always make up stuff.
Yes, but there's no reason to believe the
stuff you make up.
And there's the whole picture we have.
The physical universe hangs together and allows
you to make predictions and explain a lot
of stuff that requires there to be more than
just me.
So I would say all the evidence is in favor
of it not being just me and none of the evidence.
Now, it's not an absolute proof.
Okay, so you're just asking too much for an
absolute proof.
Reasonable people don't demand absolute proof.
They they adjust their beliefs to where the
weight of the evidence is.
Speaker 1: With many of these questions, I've
asked folks like Lawrence Krauss, for example,
about it and others, do you believe that it's
a matter of time until we answer some of these
toughest questions, or do you think it's possible
that they will never be answered?
Speaker 8: I think both.
You have to be prepared for both outcomes
because we don't have the resources to answer
that.
The best we can say is, you know, people sometimes
say, look, human intelligence evolved among
apelike creatures on the savanna.
It allowed them to survive.
It gave enough intelligence to deal with that
world.
What makes you think that that makes you smart
enough or have the right kind of intelligence
to deal with questions of cosmology or whatever?
On the other hand, you certainly have to say,
well, we've done awfully well.
I mean, we've extended science down to microscopic
and subatomic scales and to cosmological scales.
And we understand a lot about galaxy formation
and everything.
So certainly our intellectual abilities go
far beyond what we needed just in order to
survive.
How far will they take us?
Will they take us to an end, as it were? Theory.
That's just the right theory that always makes
the right predictions.
Or will we get stuck?
I don't know.
I mean, the only way to find out is to push
forward, right?
The only way to find out is to figure out
what we don't know now and investigate the
possible ways to go forward and push as hard
as you can to make a prediction about whether
we'll succeed or not.
I you know, I guess I tend to be kind of optimistic,
but I but that's just a character trait of
mine.
That's not an argument.
Speaker 1: I share that cautious optimism
that at some at some point, what are the timescales
we're thinking of, though?
I think that's where it becomes a tougher
question.
We've been speaking with Tim Modlin, who is
a professor of philosophy at New York University.
You have an ongoing project you wanted to
mention as well, is that right?
Speaker 8: Yes, I just since I have people's
attention, if you're interested in these issues,
I am the founder and director of the John
Bell Institute for the Foundations of Physics.
We are at the moment trying to raise money
on a go fund me to buy a location where we
can exist physically.
So if anybody would like to help us out, we
would appreciate any help you can give us.
You can just Google John Bell Institute to
our website or the GoFundMe Re John Bell Institute.
And it would come up.
Speaker 1: That John Bell Institute dawg as
the website but Tim Maudlin really appreciate
your time and insights today.
Thank you.
Speaker 8: Thank you.